I'm Jim Allison of immunologist
I met MD Anderson Cancer Center in
Houston or monthly among other things
the the co-director of the immunotherapy
platform where we study ways of
improving the use of immunotherapy is
manipulating the immune system of
patients to reject their own tumors
which is pretty very useful in the
clinic
I was traded about Kim
but I was just interested in the immune
system you know when I was in school I
didn't know that much about it except
it's vague idea that you had these cells
and proteins and things that they made
that could protect you but I took a
immunology class this is in the late 60s
actually when these cells called t-cells
had just been discovered and everything
you know ology before that had focused
on antibody molecules which is a protein
that protects you from bacteria and
viruses and things like that but these
t-cells all I knew at the time that I
was taught about a minister was they go
all through your body they go through
your blood they go through your tissues
and they look for things wrong with
cells they identify cells that have
something wrong with them whether
they're infected with the virus or other
kind of parasite or whether their cancer
cells and when they recognize the things
that are wrong and they eliminate them
and that is you know in cancer that that
should be perfectly completely specific
for the cancer cells and not affect
normal cells we know now it's not quite
that clean yes it is but but when I got
interested in it there was because
nobody had any clue as to how this
worked professor said you know we don't
know how they recognize the cells that
are bad we don't know what they do to to
deal with them and so I thought perfect
this is what I'm going to work on so I
started working on a full-time I guess
and about 1978 or so and still doing it
soozee azzam for immune using the immune
system treat cancer is one that's
actually been around for over 100 years
it was first proposed by paul elak in
Germany in 1906 in the 60s people began
1960s people began to start really
trying to treat cancer using in a
systematic way in patients by the 70s
and 80s there were attempts made to make
vaccines from therapeutic vaccines not
the sort that protects you from
something is going to happen but could
to jump up your immune system enough to
deal with something that you already
have anyway there were several hundred
trials conducted like that and they all
failed
then there were growth factors
discovered for t-cells and so people Jam
them into patients to try to expand
t-cells and they also failed quite toxic
- as a matter of fact but things like
this happened and it was at a point I
think when and Semler says there were
successes claimed that didn't play out
so that kind of gave a black out of the
field but this the failure to have any
successes after a while made people give
up you know so this is never gonna work
what we have to do is have better chemo
therapies and so but I had the feeling
at the time that we just didn't
understand enough about t-cells to in an
intelligent way get them to attack tumor
selves for example everybody thought
there were just on switches that she
turned a t-cell on and it did what I was
going to do and what it was through they
quit somehow and that was quite naive we
know now that these mechanism ala culés
I just talked about seeds of life or
which is the one that I discovered
actually turns the system off if you
don't have those your immune system will
do considerable damage even even a
killer and so when people were trying to
turn the immune system on they were not
recognizing that at some point you end
up turning it off because they're
pushing on the brake pedal instead of
the gas pedal basically
and so you know we should you know we
don't need to worry about turning at
home you just need to keep it from
turning off and that's basically where
this whole idea of checkpoint we call it
for these different breaks check for
blockade came about and if we just block
the those brakes and keep the immune
system running T cells specifically
running for a little bit longer than
normal they have the chance to you know
eliminate many tumors completely
[Music]